i invite you to join the discussion on
the david pakman show subreddit you can
find it at davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
we now have about 35 000 of our viewers
and listeners participating in
discussions there a few uh notable posts
i spotted this morning one was hey is
anyone else receiving memet oz text
scams and they actually posted a
screenshot of a
text scam they received that said this
dr oz report will change your life yeah
i have to tell you
i don't i i get stuff like this uh also
i get a lot of it via whatsapp
interestingly enough uh
but the i we have no evidence that this
is actually associated in any way with
dr oz nor his campaign a lot of these
things are just kind of like preying on
the
notoriety and name recognition of people
like dr oz and i i think you know report
it block it whatever
but um it it's not clear to me
that dr oz is actually sending out text
messages trying to scam people and sell
them bogus medical reports he does his
bogus medical reporting on his own show
which by the way is it even going on now
that he's running for senate i i really
couldn't tell you but um there's all
sorts of text scams i actually got a
recent one this is let me see if i can
pull this up this is an interesting one
um there's a guy called
there's this this guy in the crypto
world called mike novogratz
um he's i guess he's a gold trader or
something anyway i got a text scam about
that one where they wanted me to
give someone money to mirror the trades
of mike novogra you know i just reported
and block it right away i just pulled it
up in my trash um that doesn't mean that
these things are actually associated
with the people i'm sure that has
nothing to do with mike novograth so be
on the lookout for all sorts of
different scams but
there's many things we can slam dr oz
for i am not aware right now that he is
actually doing this uh text scamming
another post reminded our reddit users
of um
a seminal event in david pakman show
history this post says remember that
time david turned out to be a gay teen
with aids i hope i'm not the only one
who remembers now this is not a fun
aids and teen gay bullying none of it is
funny but what was funny and the the
viewer has it slightly wrong about a
decade ago
i appeared in a film
about something really sad which is
gay teens who are bullied so
relentlessly that they take their own
lives and it's horrible that's a real
thing and that happens
that didn't happen to me
and i was still featured in a
documentary with like an in memoriam
thing where i was
sort of like eulogized in a way
as a gay teen who was bullied and took
my own life and
i wasn't a teen at the time
the picture they used was of me at like
age 27. i i guess i was youthful at the
time i was not
a teen
i was not gay i was not bullied and i at
the time was very much alive so that is
an incredible moment in david pakman
show history not a not not a funny topic
um but sort of kind of curious that i
was included in that and uh
yeah
okay thanks for reminding us and then
lastly
michael cohen mentions david in his
latest podcast yeah this is cool many
people may or may not know this
trump's former lawyer michael cohen who
now is playing a really prominent role
in a number of different investigations
into trump and has a very successful
podcast and on and on
he uh he watches the david packard show
he's in our audience it's great and
we'll
we'll exchange messages sometime i was
on his show he was on my show
he sometimes will make some of the jokes
we make on this show that make it clear
he pays attention he was interviewing
kurt eichenwald
and he brought me up listen to this if
trump is so trump is president but biden
is president and the guy he's
like yes i i think that's david pakman
uh who was actually doing a video like
that i saw i saw something like that too
it was with a a husband and a wife and
he just started fumbling around you know
i mean he could not figure out none of
it makes any sense and
how can it make sense you can't you know
you it's okay anyway so that that was my
cameo by by uh name drop
on michael cohen's podcast it's a great
podcast maya culpa i do recommend people
uh check it out join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blink is for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below